When I asked my toddlers what they wanted for dinner
and they both requested Spaghettios,
I was a little taken aback.
I wasn't aware that they knew what Spaghettios were,
but nevertheless, I made them some for dinner,
cut my tomatoes in half, grated them,
and then moved on to thinly slicing my garlic and dicing up my onion.
I made sure to get a smaller dice on those.
I added some olive oil and garlic to my pot,
let that heat up on the stove
before adding in my onions and some tomato paste.
Once that had a few minutes,
I poured in my grated tomato,
leftover Parmesan rind, some oregano, salt,
a pinch of sugar, just a touch of balsamic vinegar.
Well, that was simmering.
I got started on my pasta dough by combining some eggs,
flour, salt,
oil, and kneading that until it came together
before wrapping it in plastic wrap
and letting it chill for about an hour.
I then used my pasta attachment to get shape I wanted
before cutting it into smaller pieces
and forming it into the classic spaghetti O shape.
This took me about an hour,
but it was definitely worth it.
Once they were all done, I put them into the sauce,
let them cook for about 10 minutes before it was time to serve.
I plated both of them up a bowl,
topped it with Parmesan cheese,
and they both wanted seconds.